[Music]
this episode is brought to you by
wordpress.com
I love WordPress I have used it for so
many years it's my go-to platform for
blogging and creating websites I use
wordpress.com for everything every day
my site Tim not blog is built on it the
websites for my books including tools of
titans tribe of mentors it's all on
wordpress.com and the founder matt
mullenweg
when my close friends has appeared on
this show many times just search Matt
Mullenweg tequila Ferriss for quite an
exciting time whether you're looking to
create a personal blog a business site
or both you can make a really big impact
right out of the box when you build on
wordpress.com and you'll be in good
company it's used by the New Yorker
jay-z Beyonce 5:38 TechCrunch Ted CNN
and time just to name a handful and one
of my friends at Google she'll remain
nameless has told me that wordpress.com
offers the quote best out-of-the-box SEO
imaginable end quote and it's one of the
many reasons that nearly 30% of the
Internet is run on WordPress you do not
need experience or to hire someone
that's perhaps the best part
wordpress.com guides you through the
entire experience they have hundreds of
designs and templates that you can use
and it's easy to get started there's no
need to worry about security upgrades
hosting any of that therefore 24/7
support and they're very very responsive
if you have questions they get right
back to you and this allows you to
create the highest quality with the
least amount of headache and friction so
if you're building a website period when
my friends come to me and ask what I use
what I recommend they use the answer is
wordpress.com so check it out if you
want to get started today learn more
with a 15% discount off any new plan go
to
wordpress.com forward slash tim to
create your website and find the plan
that's right for you to learn more take
a look
wordpress.com forward slash tim for
fifteen percent off a brand new website
check it out this episode is brought to
you by LegalZoom I have used LegalZoom
myself for many of my businesses and
many of the icons on this podcast have
actually used Legal Zoom for instance
Matt Mullenweg of WordPress Fame CEO of
automatic which is now worth more than a
billion dollars first incorporated his
company on Legal Zoom Legal Zoom is a
reliable resource that more than a
million people have already trusted to
help with their businesses whether
that's setting up a will doing a proper
trademark search forming an LLC setting
up a non-profit or finding simple cease
and desist letter templates man do I use
a lot of those Legal Zoom is not a law
firm but they do have a network of
independent attorneys available in most
states they can give you advice and the
best way to get started provide contract
reviews and otherwise help you run your
business and important there are no
surprises Legal Zoom provides complete
transparency that means upfront pricing
customer reviews and a satisfaction
guarantee check out Legal Zoom comm
today to see how they can make life
better and easier for you and your
business if you're pretending to be a
lawyer on the internet then you are
asking for trouble put together the
safety nets get your t's crossed and
your eyes dotted enter promo code Tim T
IM at legalzoom.com to save fifteen
percent that's t IM for fifteen percent
off check it out
legalzoom.com
[Music]
hello ladies and gentlemen and hello
Clary's you'll see why that's relevant
in a minute welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show more
specifically welcome to another edition
of the Tim Ferriss radio hour where I
share some of the habits and patterns of
world-class performers that I've
identified after nearly three hundred
three hundred guests on this podcast in
this episode we will explore fear
specifically managing mitigating
overcoming which is something I've
personally spent decades battling with
of course sometimes being paralyzed by
and fortunately in more recent years
more and more overcoming and this has
been such a focal point of my life for
extended periods that my last TED talk
focused on an exercise called fear
setting which is something that I have
found to be a life raft and that I
practice I would say at least once every
month and you can learn more about that
at Tim dup log forward slash Ted if you
want to see it it's all free and all
Specht out for you but aside from my
personal experience coming up I'll
discuss many different facets a fear or
listen to tips and tactics and so on
from folks such as Sir Richard Branson
founder and chairman of the Virgin Group
Sir Richard is of course a world famous
entrepreneur adventurer activists and
business icon his most recent book
finding my virginity shares the candid
details of a lifetime of triumphs and
failures and it provides an intimate
look at his quest to push boundaries and
that often includes breaking rules
seeking new frontiers and certainly fear
taking on coca-cola with virgin Cola and
for a while it really looked like we
were going to and topple Coke and Pepsi
and we were out selling them in the UK
then I talked to Maria Sharapova who's
the winner of five Grand Slam tennis
titles and that sense of WoW everyone
all of a sudden wants something everyone
wants something that you have everyone
wants to be a part of your success I
also discussed the relationship between
courage and fear with movie star
director and producer Vince
I would get down and I would take four
or five days and I would just not do
anything and I'd lose my energy Caroline
Paul is our last guest she is an author
who has worked as a journalist and who
also became one of the first female
firefighters with the San Francisco Fire
Department and I look around and there
was just three of us instead of four and
I remember thinking I have to go back
into that hallway and the the fear was
paralyzing so without further ado let's
jump into it and we can begin with a bit
of personal context on my part for most
of my life I would say the driving
values if you will have been security
and lack of vulnerability so it's been a
very defensive posture for a very very
long portion of my life not all of it
but optimizing was done to maximize
security decreased vulnerability and as
was told to me recently by Tony Robbins
who have had the privilege to get to
know over the last few years there are
some values that the more we obsess over
them and fixate on them the less we
perceive we have them and those could be
values or resources for example you have
respect or you have security the more
you fixate on those things the less you
perceive you have because you put on a
lens through which you see constantly
the transgressions the slights the
violations and so on and if you are
trying to in my case say control
everything for very long time the pro
and con lists the analytics the
spreadsheets all of that was to try to
control as many variables as possible
and there is a place for control but
when you try to control everything as I
did for a very long time and still
sometimes do you end up in a position
where you can be dominated by fear and
or you can feel helpless and this has
led me over decades to experience many
extended depressive periods that has led
to having a very close brush with
suicide in college
which then led to the fear sitting
exercise that I mentioned earlier and
all of that for people interested are
spelled out both in text and video all
for free at Tim de blog /head but i
don't try to figure it all out on my own
that is a mistake that I've made
repeatedly in the past and I've tried to
get better at asking for help and asking
experts to explain how they handle the
ups and downs the triumphs and the
failures the fear of the unknown and so
on that allows me to assemble a toolkit
of reminders and principles beliefs
maybe phrases that I can revisit on a
regular basis this is part of the reason
why I asked so many of my guests about
their failures and fears so let's jump
to Sir Richard Branson at Richard
Branson on Twitter and mostly everywhere
else is an English business magnate
investor and philanthropist he founded
the virgin group which controls more
than 400 companies boggles the mind
really to even think about that I have a
long history with Sir Richard's books
all the way back to losing my virginity
which I brought with me I still own it
to this day after college and it helped
to inspire one of my first businesses
and his most recent book finding my
virginity which shares the details of as
I mentioned before many of his triumphs
and failures both of which on either end
of the spectrum have been spectacular
there been some really really incredibly
noteworthy failures in Sir Richard's
life we discussed his quests to push the
boundaries stay high in life and in the
process conquer fear
when you've felt overwhelmed or an
unfocused or if you feel like you've
temporarily lost your focus what do you
do or what have you found to help you
know what questions do you ask yourself
is there in in those cases what have you
done historically that is that has been
helpful you know I personally believe
that the majority of people who have
down moments in their lives they can
they can actually trace it back quite
often to alcohol you know so perhaps
they only days my life that I feel
lethargic is you know if instead of
having you know two glasses at nighttime
I had five or six and if I find that's
happened you know on more than one or
two occasions I then give up completely
for you know a month or two and and feel
absolutely fantastic of course and
realize that I'm never going to drink
another touch about all again until
actually you do and and you know
fortunately I yeah I'm so busy that I
that I just can't afford to let myself
down too often but my guess is that the
vast majority people you know if you can
if you can be high on life and based on
healthy and and you know if you do find
that there's something like alcohol is
is is just beginning to trick you get go
bit too far you know being high in life
it's just so wonderful Campinas then for
a friend of mine entrepreneur named Matt
Mullenweg he's been on this podcast as
well he's the CEO of a company called
automatic' which is behind WordPress
which powers around 37% of the internet
right now and he told me at one point
that he had learned something along ago
which was alcohol is borrowing happiness
from tomorrow and certainly seems to be
the case I think beautiful words and
they're very very very true words you
know I mean a year
you can tell he's just so high on life
he's just enjoying enjoying it like like
he's never enjoyed it before and you
know so like if you could do it in
moderation that's great you know I tell
the story in the book there was one one
night in when we in when we won the
Grand Prix in Melbourne and anyway I let
my hair down to such an extent that it
would have made the film hanger would
look like a children's children's film
and the next day I woke up and anyway I
get a gate I gave up for six months and
and so yeah it doesn't happen to me too
often but but I think you know generally
it's generally when that's the one area
that I think a lot of a lot of people
who do you know run into problems their
lives it's just rude slightly too much
during those periods when you go off of
alcohol do you avoid circumstances where
other people are drinking or is there
something that you say to people if you
are in those circumstances how do you
ensure that you don't have just that one
drink that then triggers more drinks if
you're trying to take time away from
alcohol my trick is simply to have
cranberry and soda you know so there's a
champagne glass and I think look I think
for a lot of people you especially when
people first give up anything like that
drugs alcohol they need to walk away
complete me for a while fortunately you
know I haven't gotten you know never let
myself get to that's at that stage but
you know but I think that you know the
best advice is to you know just you know
just say I need to go to bed early
tonight them and walk away and otherwise
it's very difficult stick with it
I use now use somebody who drinks oh no
no no I don't drink
a whole lot I do enjoy wine fortunately
I don't feel like I've had any issues
with alcohol although genetically my
family seems to have that predisposition
certainly have a fair amount of
alcoholism and my extended family
so I do I think about it quite a bit I I
can I can tell that I think I have the
potential to abuse it but I haven't up
to this point I think that you and that
you and I have such fascinating lives
that you know that that is the best way
of keeping you know keeping these sorts
of things in check you know we just we
wonder if every day is so interesting
that you're just not going to want to
waste waste today right you know letting
something like that take over your life
right
no definitely and just just two more
questions for me this is one really
intended just to give people a window
into how you cope with some of the
harder times do you have a favorite
failure of yours and what I mean by that
is how has a failure or an apparent
failure set you up for later success are
there any particular examples that come
to mind yeah I mean I think on me and on
the adventure side the first time we
cross the Atlantic and both we're trying
to break the record for the pastor's
across the Atlantic and getting the blue
ribbon back and you know and we sank and
then the next day we put another boat
when we were successful and the British
people love people who are underdogs and
and it taught me that actually in
failing and then being successful most
like it was better than just going out
there and being successful the first
time around I mean the overcoming
difficulties the public almost preferred
than someone who's just successful the
first time around maybe maybe not so
much in America but in person anyway
those the most notable business failure
that we've ever had was taking on
coca-cola with virgin Cola and for a
while it really looked like we were
going to topple Coke and Pepsi and we
were out selling them in the UK the
Virgin brand resonated people loved the
drink I mean and then you know we landed
in Times Square with the Sherman tank
and you know we took on Coke in their
homeland in America and coke decided too
far back and they filled up DC tens full
of money and hit men and hit women and
they landed in the territories that we
had launched and they suddenly virgin
Cola started disappearing from all these
shelves and I think the lesson I learned
from that was you know if I'm going to
take on AG liar I've got to be got to be
different we've got to be much better
than they are and you know with a cola
you're just another Cola you're not you
can't be fundamentally different you can
be cheaper but you can't be
fundamentally different so anything
we've launched since then we've only
launched new businesses if we can make a
fundamental difference I love it
you know that's so so important to
underscore I think this is the last
rapid-fire question if you if you could
have a giant billboard
anywhere with anything on it so and this
is metaphorically speaking so getting a
message out to millions or billions of
people what would it say and why I could
be a few words could be a paragraph
could be a quote you live your life by
yours or someone else's it does anything
come to mind if you could get a message
out to billions of people what would you
what what might you put on that
billboard I think I going to sound like
a model on stage instead go back to
businessman which is you know I think
just something like nothing ventured
nothing gained I think I think that
enlightened people you know if people
you know try things and stick their neck
out they're gonna have a lot more fun
than then it takes sitting home watching
other people do it and so yeah so I
think that oh I don't quote nothing but
she's nothing gained is important having
said that you know I you know I've been
involved for 10 years now in this
wonderful group called the elders and
Nelson Mandela set it up and it's now
run by Kofi Annan and I really do
believe that in our lifetime I've seen
so many unnecessary Wars I've seen the
Vietnamese war I've seen the Iraq war
the Libyan war and these were all
incredibly unjust Wars which have you
know gone on
awful things like Isis and so on which
would not have happened if it wasn't for
actually the West taking it upon
themselves to interfere in other
countries business and killing and
maiming thousands of people and you know
we must make sure that we don't have any
wars in the future and I think it takes
business people it takes society it
takes all of us to really make sure that
our politicians never never take us down
that path again I mean one of the
saddest things I think about the
invasion of Iraq was you know yes there
were thousands of people on the streets
there should have been hundreds and
hundreds of thousands just like the
Vietnamese war to to stop such a foolish
excursion you know all all conflicts
should be able to be resolved by
negotiation and you know even if you
don't get exactly what you want out of
it that is better than better than the
all the bloodshed that flows from from
conflict maria sharapova at maria
sharapova is the winner of five Grand
Slam titles and an Olympic silver
medalist she is one of ten women in the
only Russian to hold a career Grand Slam
which refers to winning all four major
championships Wimbledon the Australian
Open the US Open and the French Open
Forbes also his name Maria the highest
paid female athlete of all time which
she first earned in 2005 she's held that
title for more than a decade is it true
that you've never used the word
rejection or that you don't believe in
that word is that true well I don't I
mean it's a very it's a very tough word
to believe in that's a very tough word
to exact I think one of the reasons is
is because I saw in many different
scenarios where my father would say no
because he would open up an opportunity
to say yes and could you okay please
explain mm-hmm
so there are many situations whether it
was a coaching opportunity or whether it
was receiving money from an agency he
had this ability to say no to the things
that seemed that like they made sense
like the easy way out because he
believed that later he'd have a better
opportunity to say yes bigger and
greater things he said no to the small
shiny objects in front at the time I'm
sure they didn't seem so not smell not
snacks
I don't rhyme in perception the short
term shiny objects may be right
so rejection it wasn't there was never
because I always had I mean I always was
following and kind of next to my father
and seeing the decisions that he would
make I was only a kid and even when I
even when I won Wimbledon I was only 17
years old you're still a kid and you're
still following the guidance and you
know I'd win a match following that and
I'd call it it's where I'd want to turn
him in and I would go shopping in a
store and I would call my mom cuz I was
something like quite pricey and I I
didn't know if I could buy it even
though I had earned that money if I
could purchase a piece of jewelry or
shoes or whatever it was at the time
that I wanted so I was always watching
and observing and they never rejection I
mean your of course when someone says no
to you it's easy to say oh yes I was I
was rejected but if you can open up a
different opportunity from that point of
view then you're turning a no into
something that's that brought you to a
better place it sounds like you did that
with your interactions with some of the
other players who were boarding at
Knicks tennis academy in a way do you
consider yourself an introvert and
extrovert a blend how do you think about
that I think from a very young age
because of sort of the process that I
that I went through
success that I earned from a young age
and winning a major and a Grand Slam at
such a young agent because it became so
unexpected I went from being someone
that was you know that someone that
people Scout it to being someone that
everyone had analyzed and knew about and
wanted to know more of and I created
this you know I definitely put on these
horse blinders because if I had not my
mind would have been everywhere and I I
think it would have been so easy to be
distracted in those moments and
situations and be pulled in different
directions which it's a slippery slope
it's very dangerous and as a young girl
it could have been a disaster to say the
least and so I definitely remember I
remember the moment and it was just a
few matches before I won Wimbledon where
I was sitting down with my coach and all
of a sudden think it was before the
semi-finals of that tournament and all
these tourists who had gotten
credentials they seemed like tourists I
didn't know who they were maybe they
would have have maybe they were maybe
they were important agents or sponsors
but at the time they just seemed like
tourists that I wanted a picture with me
and and it really came overnight and
that sense of wow everyone all of a
sudden wants something everyone wants
something that you have everyone wants
to be a part of your success I didn't
like that feeling you know I love the
feeling of being in a position of
showcasing what I could do with my
tennis racket but that feeling of
everyone wanting a piece of that and the
feeling of your opponent's all of a
sudden all of a sudden feeling like just
by beating her they're not just winning
a quarter final or the final of the
match but they're winning so much more
it made me it made me feel like I needed
to kind of put myself in a bubble to
concentrate to focus that it was going
to be that much harder that much more
difficult
and I did and I don't know if I could
have done it another way what were some
of the what are some of the best
practices or decisions that have helped
you with that because for instance my
friend Josh I was mentioning earlier who
became well-known effectively overnight
particularly with the movie about his
life for chess he could no longer
compete effectively after that because
he would go to a chess tournament and
there would be I'm making up the age but
he's something like 13 or 14 and all of
a sudden they're 20 girls who want his
attention and a bunch of reporters and
he removed himself completely from the
competitive scene he's one of the most
private people I know at this point so
what what helped you what kind of
decisions or advice or practices I think
it was surrounding myself with good
minds and good people that had my best
interest and it's so easy to say those
words but I know how difficult it is to
find those people and even harder now
nowadays and it was and I started so
many different examples of other other
tennis players and of their success and
their paths after that and the people
that knew all of a sudden associate
yourself with I think as an individual
it's very easy to be affected by the
voices that are next to you because we
listen to that and we we process that
information and all of a sudden we I
won't say we want to be like them but we
reinterpret it in our way but like when
I read when I read a funny book all of a
sudden I feel like I'm the comedian or
you know when I watch this an incredible
acting by someone it inspires me to to
be an actor you know it's like there's
moments of this that that happens as an
athlete you surround yourself with with
people's opinions or choices or money
and wealth and it's very it's such an
easy distraction and and I surrounded
myself with
people and I the friends that I have
today were my friends when I was a young
girl that my manager has managed me
since I was eleven years old you know my
mom is still very much my best friend
and another really good friend of mine I
met when I was 11 years old as well so I
have I have this fondness of developing
those real connections with people and I
think it was so helpful for me as a
young girl because I competed in front
of thousands of people and I still do
and the walk to the tunnel and the walk
to a press conference and the walk back
in the hotel room it's a very lonely
journey and that it's a difficult you
know you're in your mind a lot and
you're thinking a lot so when you have
when you have voices next to you that
are the right voices then it's so
helpful but I know how hard it is to
find but I do believe that that is a big
part of my success I have some public
exposure and have found I've made a lot
of mistakes and I found it really
difficult to identify in some cases what
ulterior motives are or if people start
doing me tons of favors I now realize
there might be something coming six
months later so I'm very hesitant to
accept favors but I can't even imagine
the level I mean I'm playing t-ball and
you're in the major leagues in the World
Series when it comes to X how many
people want a piece of you and how do
you for instance assess someone if you
say have coffee or lunch with them what
do you look out for or look for mean how
do you decide whether it's someone you
want to see a second time or talk to a
second time if anything comes to mind
and this is just business quite frankly
[Music]
I'm afraid I have 4091
unread email in my the wild in box clean
and I feel like I've a mess in my head
well we'll talk about that next but in
the meantime I think it's about I love
meeting people and I love having
conversation and I love being inspired
and you can get so much out of a
conversation or about from except by
exposing yourself to being in an
unfamiliar territory so with people and
I'll give you the a big kind of an
example that was I felt like it was
important because I'm very much I'm
always around the same people so I have
it my team which is my coach and my
fitness coach in my trainer and we
travel I see them more than my family we
travel probably 260 days out of the year
together
breakfast lunch dinner is practice
training we know so much of each other
and then you have a manager and then you
come home and then you have your friends
so I'm always surrounded by people that
I know and that I trust and that I love
which is incredible but I always think
that as a as a human being and from a
perspective of the mind and growth and
intellectually when you're put in a
situation where you're unfamiliar with
people and you're unfamiliar with their
stories or who they are and you have to
ask questions and to get that out it
makes you a much more interesting person
and so last year I put myself in this
position where I had all this time off
and it was during the summer and I
signed up for these two business courses
in Boston at Harvard Business School and
I was one out of the 40 students I
believe in each of these courses and I
stay on campus and these were
individuals who are CEOs and CEOs of
companies of Airlines of Microsoft of
all these incredible
Bram's and I was by far the youngest and
and probably the silliest and less the
least knowledgeable one in the room but
just by being with them just by sitting
with them just by sitting with them at
dinner by asking them questions by
feeling a little bit uncomfortable I
felt like at the end of those three
weeks
I grew and I grew and and it wasn't that
I mean there are definitely things that
I learned that I I'm applying and that I
wanted to apply in my business but the
biggest thing I got out of it was that I
grew as a person I I became familiar and
in a very unfamiliar territory I still
keep in touch with people in those in
the classes we have completely different
lives they're CEOs of companies they
have you know three or four kids you
know they travel all over the place and
Here I am a thirty year old athlete but
there's so much respect in that room
because we're all trying to learn and to
grow and so when I when you asked me
like who are the people that you want to
meet with or speak to or have a coffee
with I always think of that and the
people that I choose to be with are the
people that I want to learn from and
that I want to have a conversation with
and not just about what they bought at
the flea market or you know what they're
gonna how they're how they like their
coffee but it's about the world and it's
about education it's about people and
and it's not about right or wrong I
don't always have conversation because I
want to know what makes someone perfect
and not I like to hear opinions and I
got out of that experience in Boston and
I know I felt like I grew I felt like I
stepped up and I got out of my comfort
zone and and I followed up with them and
and we still keep in touch about
business and projects and things like
that so it was a very interesting
experience personally for me
Vince Vaughn at Wild West on Twitter is
one of the most prolific actors writers
and producers in the world he's acted in
more than 30 major motion pictures that
have gone on to grossed more than 1.7
billion at the box office he's largely
credited for redefining the r-rated
comedy with his performance in the 2005
hit wedding crashers which set the
record for highest grossing r-rated
comedy at the time he is and will
continue to be I expect one of the most
sought-after leading men in Hollywood
I met Vince because he listened to this
podcast and he reached out through his
production company wild west to see if
we might do a TV show together
specifically he had seen one of my first
TED Talks it was actually recorded at
something called the eg the
entertainment gathering where I talked
about language learning dance and
swimming three fears that I overcame
using different toolkits with the help
of mentors and we discussed many
different options and we settled on a
show that ended up being called fearless
with the less in parentheses and it's in
parentheses because the objective of the
show where I interviewed everyone from
David Blaine the illusionist and
endurance artist to Kyle Maynard and
Stewart Copeland of the police and so on
the objective was and is to teach people
to fear less to words to fear less which
is trainable not to be fearless which is
not the objective at all you know one
great thing about failure is you realize
it's not as bad as your mind makes it
out to be it script the fear is more
crippling than the actual consequences
the consequence is a lot of times feel
almost relieving in a way because now
you've aced it you've gone through it
and that kind of takes that away from ya
know it's amazing how also over time the
more you you don't address your fear and
meaning if you take some large fear and
you break it down into the smallest
possible steps let's say for swimming
for me is even just putting my face
underwater for a period of time right so
forget about swimming forget about
learning how to breathe just putting
your face underwater
and then when you finally have the
incentive like this bet that I had with
my friend or rather this mutually
assigned year's resolution with a
deadline was up with a deadline yeah
with a deadline when I actually sat down
and found a method of swimming called
total immersion which I recommend
everybody which was introduced to me by
Chris Sacca who also had difficulty
swimming and he said I have the answer
your prayers it took me a week about 10
days to go from zero elapsed and a Perl
to like 40 laps of workout as meditation
it was an incredibly it was in it was
incredibly easy compared to the mental
monster that I had created for myself
that's what's fascinating is how much of
it is the woods that we've created now
versus the actual path to the
destination you were as I understand it
rejected for certain roles because of
your height is that true I mean that
leaving leading men at the time or that
the rules they were casting for or maybe
the people you'd be featured with would
be shorter and the issues there that
that that ended up being an issue in the
early days I think whatever you're
getting rejected for they find a reason
to say it you know I think when I was
going up for roles younger and I was so
much taller than people they would say
that I'm sure it played a role into it
but I think it's important whatever
you're doing that you don't give voice
to things that you're not able to change
you would have to use it in a way to
find ways to do stuff it's all neutral
ultimately even if it doesn't feel that
way
on some level at least for the purposes
of approaching stuff but you know look
at the end of the day it's just a lot of
rejection it's the nature of it so I had
that turned on it probably a thousand to
one for the times that I would audition
or more and it wasn't always consistent
the reasons why but all you knew was
that you weren't getting a chance to
participate and so you would have to go
back to the lab and try to get to a
place of being more and more undeniable
and when you are going through all these
rejections of course at a certain point
it just becomes second nature to not
flinch as much when you get turned down
for something but if you were giving
advice to say and not becoming actor who
has some degree of talent but it's
rejected and they're they're really just
feeling like they're getting punched in
the face by the world what would you say
to that person well I think I looked at
it mathematically at a certain point
which was I I started just focusing my
entire day on perfecting my craft so it
was either watching a movie reading a
book on stuff doing monologues taking
classes and I drink products from
infomercials ordering products for
mercer's came later that was the dessert
that was a treat for her I got a chance
to work but I would deny myself other
things I couldn't go do this I couldn't
travel until I earned it so I would deny
myself certain things that I would want
to do and say to haven't earned that yet
which I find to be a good motivator and
then what I did was if I would screen
test for a movie that was a big
opportunity that would have been
life-changing it would have given me an
opportunity what is screen testing I was
an idiot I'll ask
screen test would be your clothes
there's a couple people for a role and
now they're gonna film a scene from the
movie with you and perhaps the already
cast an actor or just pair people
together and then screen testing they
would just see who mixes and matches or
how do you do on camera how do they feel
you come off and I had a couple of those
maybe four or five four good
opportunities and when you don't get it
so you could go to seven or eight
auditions to get to this point is
between you and two or three other
people and when you don't get it your
day the next day doesn't change meaning
you still are gonna get asked to go in
for five lines on a television show or
something smaller there is no
advancement as far as opportunity you
you were just a person with the same
credits you had so there was a lot of
time spent to get to that and energy to
get to that moment and if it didn't pan
out there was no change in how somewhat
you were no more castable as a known
entity than what you were so what would
happen is when you would get that close
and it wouldn't happen at first I would
get down and I would take four or five
days and I would just not do anything
and I'd say oh this is lose my energy
and then I started to realize that the
week I took off was really two weeks
that it was a week of not getting better
and it was a wee
of getting worse and I said now I've
given myself two weeks less to improve
that the things I'm in control of and I
started looking at it like a percentage
game the more I worked on things my
percentages would go up and what I
realized later was it gave you a
confidence to feel like you belong there
it gave you permission to perform in
situations that didn't feel comfortable
because you had felt good about what you
had brought to the table and so I would
suggest that you find a process where
you're able to I think it's important to
allow yourself to feel disappointed I
think it's important that you don't turn
off those feelings but it is also
important to how do you do that as
quickly as possible that to then become
a productive again and start doing the
things that are going to give you a
better opportunity for what you want the
same could be said for a relationship it
hurts your feelings is but how much time
is the effective in mourning and
processing it I really believe no time
is not good you need that moment to
accept it but the sooner you can get
back to doing things for your own growth
and the things you're in charge of I
think your chances of having the things
you want in your life become greater I
think also from what I've observed in
you and other people you've done really
well in their respective fields is that
having an opportunity to be exposed to
micro failures in some environment like
wrestling like auditions inoculates you
in such a way that you develop a
tolerance for rejection and that allows
you to capitalize on opportunities much
more effectively later because you don't
take the two weeks off right correct and
it allows you to improve so but then we
have the problem on the other side which
I don't know if you've experienced you
see if the boxers a lot but once you
have a level of success can you maintain
a motivation right to have the approach
that you once had right when the
immediate needs are not there as strong
sure because I think on some level we
all are looking for those things in life
how to let go of stuff and how to enjoy
things in a more productive way could
you talk about your car accident in high
school sure yeah
it's not something that we've talked
about no I'm gonna talk about it much
what we were it was after school I had
played sports and then I had stopped I
had started getting more into acting and
it was during the day and I was a
passenger and it was raining out and the
girl that was driving was swerving on
the road being cute I remember was
saying don't swerve don't don't you know
stop it but she kept doing it we were go
maybe 35 miles an hour and then we
hydroplane
and I woke up in a ditch my thumb ripped
up real bad and I couldn't move my legs
couldn't move I had paramedics over me
and I have blood all around me I was
real concerned my friend I didn't have
any idea how I looked I wasn't tracking
it
my friend was real bloody I said it's
Shaun okay they said yeah he's alright
they got me the ambulance and then they
couldn't get ahold of my parents at
first as they were worth traveling and
so I just remember being in a lot of
pain there was a moment you didn't know
what the ramifications were I had a
small compression which turned out to be
nothing in my back but and the aesthetic
of my thumb being injured I at the time
I didn't I mean it's now just a very bad
scar on the back side of it and
thankfully I have the thumb and can move
it but there's a pad that was gone so
that was um that was challenging because
it really made me evaluate the oldest
cliche you know without your health yeah
you don't have anything so I really got
the experience of feeling like well what
if I can't move around or people go
outside and play and things I had taken
for granted and then this the anything
physical that is different that you're
used to in a certain way I think at
first its natural to feel insecure about
it and here I was and at that time
knowing one to pursue being an actor and
entertainer so it was a gift in you know
processing things and putting your focus
on other things and you started to
realize the power of your own inner
dialog far as what you were creating or
not so there was a lot of gifts in it
ultimately
but at the time it was I feel lucky for
it and that it was without real
consequences it was a it was a nice
learning gift in a way just to we're
gonna talk a lot about that inner
dialogue and self-talk but I don't want
to touch on a few things that are around
that same time period and as maybe a
preface to that I will say that Vince is
one of the most consistently curious
people I've ever met were just saying
luck so my job is to interview curious
people and to give you an idea we were
just backstage getting miked up and he
had questions about something called the
Marcelo team so Marcelo team is a joke
that's used in Brazilian Jujitsu by the
Michael Jordan / Wayne Gretzky of
grappling his name is marcelo garcia so
i was backstage choking vince about ten
minutes ago and there are a lot of very
nervous looks very effectively I will
it's a good joke that Lowe knows what
he's doing and grappling was one of the
first things wrestling specifically that
we bonded over mm-hmm and could you talk
about the role of sports I and wrestling
to the extent that it's that had a
lasting impact I think it's important I
think you know George Washington I think
credited ballroom dancing and horseback
riding is two of the most important
things he did because it gave him
confidence physically in grace and you
know being a leader I don't know that
you could put grace in the body without
you know whether it's I took ballet that
took played sports I think it's
important especially for me being tall
it allowed me to have I think more
control and confidence in my and my um
my height in and so wrestling to me was
really a course in resiliency and
discipline I would have loved to have
eight other team sports but it was I was
very good at wrestling for whatever
reason and I wasn't as accepted and some
of the team sports so rustling is very
much a loner sport if you're on a team
bus you kind of joke around and laugh on
a wrestling
everyone is dead silent partially
because they're all dehydrated from
cutting weight cutting weight and you're
gonna get in the fight in front of your
school or people you don't know it's
like you shake hands and it's like
you're gonna you know there's no one
missed a block you got you've got B
right and you are dehydrated it's odd
and that you're growing and yet you're
trying to maintain a weight as I mean
it's especially when you're doing it
when you're younger it's very
challenging but I really felt that I got
and there's you know you would come out
of playing football feeling like you
were in shape and then you would go and
wrestling and you would realize you're
not in any kind of shape because if you
just wrestle it's exhausting and then
the only other thing you can do is run
and in the winter in Illinois that meant
hallways and stairs we had a coach list
he got fired he was not fit to be with
the kids but I I felt like I was look I
benefited from having that personality
but he was a real problem but I remember
I feel like we needed a little more
elaboration so people's minds don't go
crazy well he was he was he was he had a
real anger problem he would hit okay he
just I got hit this isn't spotlight I
just want him yeah he punched me once in
the chest after a match it went out of
me he would he encouraged kids hurting
each other but it seemed normal at the
time you know he was like the Cobra Kai
yeah he was like Cobra Kai it was crazy
he had his own emotional issues so we
would win a meet like 62 X or whatever
it was and he would be angry over the
few mistakes and he would it was at some
point you just for the emotion being
poured on you remember his sister was an
assistant he'd always say get me a tab
in an aspirin or an advil go get me my
go get me a tab and a half advil and
he's keep screaming at us but he would
sometimes like there was a you know he
would run these he stairs and he would
say in these hallways it was like a
spread but he didn't make it under a
minute 20 you would add another one
right he was intentionally you were
gonna have the bar moved and he was
trying to break your spirit he wanted to
simulate all is lost what you thought
was gonna get you there is not and not
will you stand right but inevitably the
second-string heavyweight was never
gonna make that time so the first time
he would do it he'd say okay he's called
the kid's name loud
was uh Illinois so it was either I think
it was I remember the name I won't say
it might have been like Eastern European
last name and he said he was late so
then the first time he'd run after that
there'd be some encouragement come on
you could do it but the second or third
time kids would start yelling and
screaming at him or kicking at him and
really physically forcing him was like a
like a bad episode bad a few good men
yeah it was terrible and I always had a
problem with the third Authority anyway
and I clash with him a lot I ended up
just showing up at the meets and I was
good enough that I could do that I
wouldn't go to practices all the time I
really had problems with him but he did
punch me one time with the chassis but
he turned out to be someone that created
a past that was not truthful he had told
us that he made the Olympic team but
that it was when the year that we
boycotted it it turned out not to be
true you know but anyway I guess the
long version of it is I think that I
gained all more than I lost even with
him being challenging in a lot of ways I
wouldn't change that experience and you
can have a great coach which there are
in wrestling and I think in general one
of the great attributes of wrestling is
Constitution and grit the ability to
survive painful moments and not take
them on in the absolute sense meaning to
have perspective on pain
Caroline Paul at Cairo writer CA ro
writer on Twitter is an author of
fiction and nonfiction she worked in
public radio as journalists before
joining the San Francisco Fire
Department in 1988 as one of their first
female firefighters she worked most of
her career on rescue to where she and
the crew were responsible for search and
rescue and fires rescue two members were
also trained and sent on scuba searches
she has some horrifying stories of
pulling out decomposing bodies rope and
rappelling rescues surf rescues confined
space searches all hazardous material
calls and the most severe train and car
wrecks her first book was the nonfiction
memoir fighting fire published in 1998
she also wrote the New York Times
bestseller and a book that I think is
fantastic called the gutsy girl she
calls it lean in for girls but I think
it's actually much more than that and
it's not set in the boardroom but rather
in trees on cliff edges and in wild
rivers she is very very good at
recognizing how resilience and toughness
gutsiness can be trained it can be
taught and in a controversial New York
Times essay the proceeded publication of
that book she wrote that risk teaches
kids responsibility problem-solving and
confidence you can certainly find it
very easily by searching caroline paul
new york times her perspective on fear
and how she overcomes it in the most
extreme circumstances
she's done losing she's done all sorts
of extreme sports her approach was
extremely helpful and inspiring and
valuable to me personally and I hope the
same for you when you think of the
moments you've been most terrified what
are those moments that come to mind they
don't have to be physical danger they
could be but what are what are the
moments that first come to mind for you
well I think the time that I was
probably the most physically scared and
it was a bit of an unusual feeling for
me and I'm not trying to say that I'm
super brave I just had this ability to
really take fear and put it way way back
in line of all my other emotions when I
was a firefighter
but I was in a I talk about this in the
book actually I was in a fire building
and I was with my crew and I was
we're in teams of two so the the the the
team who was ahead of me Frank and Andy
and then I had my crew mate was behind
me Viktor he and I were together but we
were all crawling down the same hallway
and we had a hose line which was unusual
but they couldn't find the fire so the
chief goes hey guys we you guys grab a
hose line so we're psyched to do that
it's awesome to go find the heat the
seat of the fire and it's super smoky
hot and kind of quiet in this weird way
and then all of a sudden a huge
explosion which pushed us all out of the
hallway and we're what we realized later
was that there had been a flashover
not in the hallway which would have
killed us but somewhere close enough by
- just one little slash over a flashover
is when the room gets so hot that even
the particles in the air simultaneously
ignite so basically this just huge was
like a gas blast basically yeah I've
been in those - and those are not those
are will knock your mask off and throw
you backwards and I remember being sort
of discombobulated and in the garage and
my friend Frank goes where's Victor
Victor was my crew mate and I look
around and there was just three of us
instead of four and I remember thinking
I have to go back into that hallway and
the the fear was paralyzing this all
tooks milliseconds and I see Frank who's
super brave really great firefighter
just turned and start to just catapult
himself towards that door to find Victor
and for me it was only a millisecond but
I was scared and I recognized that fear
and that fear scared me more than the
fear itself because when you're
paralyzed as a firefighter and your
friend is missing that that's the worst
and so of course I was right on his
heels but I that feeling of
overwhelming fear was really sobering
for me and but what I learned of course
is that you can be scared that's okay
but you still have to take action if
it's necessary and then my friend was
fine he had actually been blown out too
but he he took shelter on the other side
we we were found ourselves in the garage
so it all ended up fine but it was a
moment I'll never forget
see you've mentioned in your writing for
instance the your ability to put fear
behind your other emotions and the story
that comes to mind for me is the and we
don't necessarily have to go into the
details of this right now but the
climbing of the Golden Gate Bridge which
by the way folks listening illegal I
wouldn't recommend doing it especially
now after 2001 yeah they will shoot you
they will shoot you so not it's all a
lark in the 90s not anymore seven
hundred and sixty some odd feet or
something along those lines seventy
maybe maybe 720 I don't know you
probably have a better memory of the
elevation than I but where did you
develop that ability or how did you
develop that ability like for someone
listening is like God you know I'm so
fearful how can I develop that same
ability to take say courage or desire or
whatever it might be enthusiasm and try
to put it in front of this dominant
emotion that I have and default emotion
which is fear what would you what would
you say to them and I guess that's two
questions how do you develop it and
would you say to them but you can tackle
it any way it like well I am NOT against
fear let me just say right up front I
think fear is important is definitely
important it's there to keep us safe but
I do feel like some people give it too
much priority it's one of the many
things that we use to assess a situation
so I'm not against fear but I am pro
bravery so that's my paradigm so once I
know that fear is just one of many
things that are going on so Francis
when we climb the bridge which was five
of us deciding we wanted to walk up that
cable in the middle of the night please
don't do that but we did and it was a
really I mean talk about fear I mean
you're walking on a cable we have to put
one foot in front of the other and you
get higher and higher until you're
basically a honest as high as a 70
storey building and with nothing below
you and holding on to these two thin
wires on either side it's just a walk
technically really nothing's gonna
happen unless some earthquake or sudden
catastrophic gust of wind which was
really not going to happen you're gonna
be fine as long as you keep your mental
state intact don't panic it's just a
walk and so what I do in those
situations is I look and look at all the
emotions I'm feeling which is
anticipation exhilaration focus
confidence fun and fear and then I take
fear and say well how much priority am I
gonna give this I really want to do this
and then I put it where it belongs and
it's it's kind of like bricklaying no no
no you just look at all the bricks and
you were making a stone wall you fit the
pieces together so do or have you
literally I should use that word
carefully in my life in general but
visualized the bricks or like to someone
who hasn't had this practice and you're
you're gonna give them sort of a
meditation exercise right the next time
you're feeling fear do this how what
would you advise them to do yeah I
actually want someone to partition each
emotion as if it's a little separate
block and then put it in a line because
once you not only look at your emotions
but also assess your own skill and the
situation often things change
I mean we're scared supposedly I hear
people say I'm so scared of
fill-in-the-blank picking up an insect
really what is really so scary about an
insect seriously
is it gonna eat you know so as long as
you stop and really look I think
people's lives will change kind of
radically especially for women because
women are very very quick to say they're
scared and that's something I really
want to change this is Caroline Paul and
I'm really happy to be back with all of
you and Tim on the Tim Ferriss podcast
for round two and you sent me a bunch of
questions and I'm gonna answer some of
them
thanks so much let's just dive right in
so no name asked if you're trying to
change your relationship with fear where
do you start it's hard to face it when
it's breathing down on you any tips well
first of all congratulations on changing
your relationship to fear I don't know
if you're a woman but if you are this is
an especially big step because as I've
talked about I feel really strongly that
we as women have been so encouraged to
be fearful that it's an underpinning of
our life that were often not even
conscious of so just taking this step is
amazing here's my tip it's really
straight forward micro bravery because
here's a concept that a great
organization calls girls leadership
really articulate it to me which is that
bravery is learned and like anything
learned it just needs to be practiced
and the way we practice things is to
start small so micro bravery this is
what they call it I love that micro
bravery is basically breaking down your
fears into either smaller steps or just
start starting small with any fear and
the reason we want to do that is because
well first of all you become aware of
what it feels like to be fearful because
here's the truth and I think I've talked
about this on the podcast before but
fear feels a lot like excitement has the
same physiological characteristics of
you know high heart
rate the sweat nervous tension and so
often what we do especially as women
because we're really not taught to
discern the nuances of fear because we
aren't taught to value bravery like men
are so we aren't taught to really move
through it is that it feels so similar
to excitement that we often mistake the
fact that we are not actually completely
subsumed with abject fear we actually
are feeling fear and other things
excitement exhilaration anticipation
curiosity things that really will open
up our life and that actually is telling
us hey this this new experience is going
to be kind of cool but because and again
often it's women we don't we haven't
practiced bravery so we don't really
understand what we're feeling in times
of stress or where we're pushing outside
we're comfort zones so when you practice
bravery and really what you're
practicing is micro bravery you get
really comfortable and you start to
understand what fear feels like and you
start to discern all the nuances of that
emotion so the second thing you become
knowledgeable about is what bravery is
because I think a lot of women don't
really have a sense of what that feels
like either in fact I like to to turn
around maybe even this question and say
well it's not really changing a
relationship to fear it's changing a
relationship to bravery and so what
we're doing and I know I talked about
this before is it we are valuing a
bravery paradigm instead of a via fear
paradigm because I do think we give
permission to women to talk about fear a
lot and to really emphasize it in ways
that make it that perpetuates it the
last thing you do is when you're
practicing micha bravery you really
start to develop a process of moving
from fear to bravery
and that process when you use it in
small instances you can apply when you
confront fear in bigger instances and
that can be an emotional fear and that
can be fear you know in in in your
workplace and that can also be fear in
the outdoors now when you practice micro
bravery I really want kids is to
practice it in the outdoors because it's
really fun the outdoors and it's a
really great way to understand that line
between being scared and then excitement
and then going to bravery because it's
just more obvious than if you're trying
to practice it in a more emotional
situation but as adults I know you
already know whether you like the
outdoors or not this is not about like
oh you have to be in the outdoors to be
brave not true you guys who are not so
much outdoors you can practice in at
home or in the workplace small acts of
micro bravery again really important
this is something you start small so
that you really get to know yourself and
bravery better an analogy might be
deciding you're gonna run a 5k you don't
just go run a 5k on the day of the race
you practice and you practice in small
increments you start by walking you
start by then you proceed to running a
little bit you get the picture so it's
you breaking it down and in that way
your training and your training to
understand your body like a runner and
you're treating to understand your own
mind
[Music]
well there you have it folks I hope you
enjoyed this episode on overcoming or
managing or perhaps even using fear
doesn't have to be a negative it can be
something that is useful it can be a
fuel it can be a call to action and now
I'm gonna pass the mic over to you guys
please let me know what you liked or
disliked about this episode let me know
what you want to hear more about what
topics would you like me to explore you
can shoot me a note on twitter at t--
ferrous TF er Riss or leave a comment on
the blog at tim dot blog forward slash
podcasts and you can find the show notes
for this episode until next time thank
you all so much
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every Friday that provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that I've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of weird [ __ ] that I've
somehow dug up in the the world of the
esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoy
[Applause]
this episode is brought to you by
LegalZoom I have used LegalZoom myself
for many of my businesses and many of
the icons on this podcast have actually
used LegalZoom for instance Matt
Mullenweg of WordPress Fame CEO of
automatic which is now worth more than a
billion dollars first incorporated his
company on LegalZoom LegalZoom is a
reliable resource that more than a
million people have already trusted to
help with their businesses whether
that's setting up a will doing a proper
trademark search forming an LLC setting
up a non-profit or finding simple cease
and desist letter templates man do I use
a lot of those LegalZoom is not a law
firm but they do have a network of
independent attorneys available in most
states they can give you advice on the
best way to get started provide contract
reviews and otherwise help you run your
business and important there are no
surprises LegalZoom provides complete
transparency that means upfront pricing
customer reviews and a satisfaction
guarantee
check out legalzoom.com today to see how
they can make life better and easier for
you and your business if you're
pretending to be a lawyer on the
internet then you are asking for trouble
put together the safety nets get your
t's crossed and your eyes dotted enter
promo code Tim T IM at legalzoom.com to
save 15% that's t IM for 15% off check
it out
legalzoom.com this episode is brought to
you by wordpress.com
I love WordPress I have used it for so
many years it's my go-to platform for
blogging and creating websites I use
wordpress.com for everything every day
my site Tim not blog is built on it the
websites for my books including tools of
titans tribe of mentors it's all on
wordpress.com and the founder matt
mullenweg
when my close friends has appeared on
this show many times just search matt
mullenweg tequila Ferriss for quite an
exciting time whether you're looking to
create a personal blog a business site
or both you can make a really big impact
right out of the box when you build on
wordpress.com and you'll be in good
company
it's used by The New Yorker jay-z
Beyonce 538 tech
ted CNN and time just to name a handful
and one of my friends at google shall
remain nameless has told me that
wordpress.com offers the quote best
out-of-the-box SEO imaginable end quote
and it's one of the many reasons that
nearly 30 percent of the internet is run
on wordpress you do not need experience
or to hire someone that's perhaps the
best part wordpress.com guides you
through the entire experience they have
hundreds of designs and templates that
you can use and it's easy to get started
there's no need to worry about security
upgrades hosting any of that therefore
24/7 support and they're very very
responsive if you have questions they
get right back to you and this allows
you to create the highest quality with
the least amount of headache and
friction so if you're building a website
period when my friends come to me and
ask what I use what I recommend they use
the answer is wordpress.com so check it
out if you want to get started today
learn more with a 15% discount off any
new plan go to wordpress.com forward
slash tim to create your website and
find the plan that's right for you so
learn more take a look
wordpress.com forward slash tim for 15%
off a brand new website check it out
check it out check it out check it out
check it out check it out check it out
check